hey there I don't think we've met my  name is Harrison  I teach super powers the powers a  program on my youtube channel to cover  everything from the basics of Python to  more advanced topics like data  visualization analysis natural language  processing robotics machine learning  pattern recognition making games  michaelbay editions of games making  supercomputers making websites and a  whole lot more I've got hundreds of  videos I put out several videos a week  on average and the only way to keep up  is by subscribing  so what are you waiting for you can  click anywhere on this video and  subscribe to my channel and you too can  have super powers but of course with  great power comes great responsibility  alright that is going to get dangerous  fast  you